Emma Kratz aren't letting go of
impeachment even while the pandemic is
going on they're still trying to get
their hands on redacted grand jury
material from the Muller probe here's
Donald Trump sounding off earlier
nobody's been abused by Pfizer like the
President of the United States the top
of the FBI they were dirty cops they
were crooked bad people these people
they broke the law they broke the law
what they've done to general Flynn
should never happen what they've done to
the presidency and what they've done to
this country can never be allowed to
happen again to our country and we've
got our hands on a fully Declassified
Susan Rice email from January 2017
describing an oval office meeting about
the Russia investigation it shows the
Obama administration had a laser focus
on Mike Flynn and former FBI director
James Comey even suggested sensitive
information on Russia not be shared with
Flynn all right judge Janine this never
stops what do you think's going on now
well you know what I think is
fascinating Jessie is that the the the
email that was written by Susan Rice on
the day that the president Trump was
being sworn in he's nothing more than a
self-serving statement which is
generally not allowed in a courtroom if
you're the defendant but it also to me
as a you know as a former prosecutor is
an admission it is consciousness of
guilt it is building a defense for
Barack Obama when in fact no one has
asked it's like the police come to your
house and you say I didn't shoot my wife
okay but she's upstairs and she's dead
of a gunshot wound why are you even
phrasing it like that and the other part
of this is that you know when you read
what they say she says the president is
not initiating or instructing anything
and that the law enforcement needs to do
what it does by the book and be mindful
that we cannot entertain or share
information possibly about Russia with
the Trump administration that's
basically saying that Obama said
consider not giving this information to
Trump I mean she couldn't she could only
say it clearly more clearly if she left
one word and by by the Democrats trying
to get the grand jury testimony of the
Muller investigation first of all think
of the fact that this was the most anti
Trump organization invested
investigation going and secondly there's
nothing else in there they found there
was no collusion so it's all just
building up to getting Trump out of
office Dana what do you think
well I think that impeachment 2.0 is
actually going to be impeachment
infinity because as long as President
Trump is in office the Democrats will
say that they are trying to impeach him
or looking into impeachment and even I
mean basically having their rear ends
handed to them in January on the vote
they still continue to pursue it and
partly that's because their base the
left wing will demand that and so
they're trying to you know fulfill that
demand on the grand jury testimony I had
trey gowdy on the daily briefing today
and he made a great point I'm sure the
judge would agree is that grand jury
testimony is secret for a reason because
prosecutors take the grand jury
testimony and they indict or they don't
there's no middle ground like you don't
get to go in and look at grand jury
testimony just because you're curious
and because you want to do something
political now I do think that Lindsey
Graham's hearing that he's planning to
hold on the Senate side will probably
get a lot more answers than anything
else and these you know were
declassifying emails we have lists now
there's a lot more information now than
they even had in January when they were
trying to impeach him in the Senate yeah
that Graham investigation can't come
soon enough Gregg impeachment infinity
that sounds like a nice line yeah it
reminds me of like how I got I just lost
track of all the Star Wars sequels you
know after the second one I just stopped
but the real that I guess the truth is
the Democrats would rather beat Trump
than a virus they think about this you
have an election in six months God knows
what's gonna happen before them
so why impeachment I think it's because
they actually fear good news they know
that possibly the bet the next phase
will be incredible for America as
we get back to work there's gonna be an
unbridled sense of optimism in hope and
that's gonna help Trump because he's the
king of optimism and they can't have
that so the they need to combat good
news with this impeachment which is
nothing but a smear and it exposes their
naked priorities what kind of naked
priorities do you have mr. Williams oh I
believe in the Constitution and the
founding fathers and that Congress is an
equal branch of government with every
right to request what they need in terms
of oversight and that if there's a
conflict we have the judiciary to settle
the issue and in this case what we know
is that the US Court of Appeals ruled in
March Jessie that Congress has a right
to see the full report and that what we
know now is that in fact it's Trump's
Justice Department that has redacted the
Mulla report won't let people see it
apparently out of fear that it will
reveal obstruction in terms of the Roger
stone case in case now Michael and
that's why they're firing lightly
confident is to report it no no it's the
Congress of the United States that has
the legal right to this information but
I guess people want to cover up for the
president no matter what no that's
that's absolutely not the case
we're all here all right oh yeah no no
see you know you've actually seen too
much